prosciutto Cocteau illa for nacho
gorgonzola broccoli a spinachy--
questa è una fecha de salami ill
prosciutto crudo
la mozzarella la melanzana in pepperoni
pepperoni Rosso red and in pepperoni
Charlo yellow la Sukeena
or look to Kino
both are good these are our old friends
Aldo Coppola and peperoncino no you
Geneva la chuga chuga basilica lorry
gana el sol salt la passata D Pomodoro
Lacroix
that's water in be carbonate Oh
so do L little Easton tener la laa la
pagina oggi siamo ill for no purpose in
our la pizza
mmm who's Yama who ke4 Nellie stove Phil
couch in our live will direct the
vegetable side once again because of a
lotion a quick pizza usually you would
have to start to eat pizza many hours in
advance because we use East and then you
have to wait for the dough rise for 1
hour
we don't have time to clear classes the
afternoon so we will make usual we're
going to need once the dough is ready we
will prepare our and we have different
choices of toppings based on your tastes
last time I asked you what did you like
you like well here we have some of our
old favorites
we know each of them right now what is
this well you will use it on the
singular this is you know speaker
pictures yeah yeah
yeah
so we don't have more than one thing we
had more we'd say
and crudo cotton it's cooked
crudo rock very much not a pizza every
movie some young some of the battles
sweeper mainly three four days like I'm
just late into different groups anybody
have a chance to prepare the little low
dose but the first group will start with
the dough and the second group will
start by washing and cooking the
vegetables because we want to cook them
a little bit